logo quem fala é dark do dio muito bem
vindos mas não ganhe a mostrar dizer que
uma coisa muito perigosa muito perigosa
e não é baixo já vamos ver novos tempos
atrás que incluem muita coisa brinquedos
quando estava em controlo pistola de
brincar muita coisa eu encomendei do
amazonas que normalmente vai estar no
limite então só para eu tocar essas
coisas todas o que quer dizer que vou
contar tudo e mais coisas assim mas não
só que eu comprei provedores pessoal é
uma terra muito macio ela é linda
nós estávamos que eu adoro e linhas não
aquelas linhas pequenas que pudesse
atendimento eu já fiz um vídeo atingiram
maranhão pequena cama por seu lado o
estudo lembro eu não percebi porquê
dessas pequenas têm muito mesmo as
maiores tranqüilos f-1000 adoro adoro
mesmo muito lindas e esta matéria ampla
brutal que o que vai acontecer que uma
pessoa que eu vou andar à solta com ela
aqui em casa e vou tentar ajustar o
pessoal aqui de casa espero que sejam
todos em casa no hospital e vejam só
aqui na casa disse textura e eu estou
realmente fixou a nova estrela da música
inglês mova as patas
obviamente ela tem que encher os padres
não é e brilham os olhos brilham indo aí
descobrimos aqui nossa aranha para
tentar bater uma meta vamos tentar
chegar aos 200 mil likes neste vídeo
sério vamos tentar manter essa meta
mesmo 200m light só nós atingimos essa
meta dos 200.000 light eu vou comprar
uma tonelada de material pra mim era um
desafio de seu door tranqüilos que eu
não estava tendo uma tarântula como
animal de estimação miley pessoa faz
quando atingiu então os 200m light e vou
comprar uma tranquila para mim uma
tranquila real e vou alimentar levou
comprar a casa dela e todas essas coisas
mas temos que manter essa meta só agora
lá e agora vamos abrir a nossa tarântula
gripe muitas estudos só ela tem uma
textura bem estranha é que rompeu é
consultor helmut dela meu e é como se
fosse um caminho ela tem escola está em
outra roda em baixo e propriedade por
espinhas aqui olha só o meu computador
ela tem todo meu ver o pessoal tá em
casa basta estar muito mas muito agora
eu tenho que fazer é só pôr as pilhas e
um homem feito em pilhas aa em casa eu
não sair vou procurar
não só conta aí fui comprar pilhas agora
eu tive que comprar porque esta é uma
filha bem estranha que ela encontre zona
ou menos como está a funcionar agora só
faltaria agora como é que se você não
comprar agora vai cair 3 2 1
uau
aqui ganha e vamos lá 32 vai sozinha
toque mais brio sabem é completamente
preta eu acho que ela teve de cortar e
combater estava em toda a linha venenosa
tem contente por me amar é ou pode se
quiser que algumas aranhas cobras mais
venenosas do mundo e vamos ver qual é
mais penosa e vamos tentar pintar anotar
ano e meio mas pode ficar brutal para lá
ok agora só quem não tem céu pode ser
vista que já muito grande até bancos a
respeitar o que é bem grande mas vamos
aplicar aqui 30 mesmo assim já que já
fez o que o padrão é muito simples que
suas palavras são um pouco vamos tentar
assim só avançaram um pouco de maio e
olha só fiquei um pouco a imagem do
estado
vejam só como é que fica uma gosto mas
assim a tv que o lado mais minutos
qualquer representou a lei só ficou o
portal e quente mas ela vai ficar
infectado com veneno e internet eu já
toquei que já tenha infectado e bons o
álbum ela então tentar assustar o
pessoal aqui em casa eu acho que estão
todos cá eu vou tentar os estados como
por um esconder a câmera eu não sei se
vai dar certo mas bora lá sua prima
nacional
o em meio ao frio não tinha como eu
estava com muito medo dela
valeu justiça
[Música]
no meu email olá lá com muita vontade de
fazer aqui uma batalha da era dunga com
aranha ninguém lá e aqui
[Aplausos]
agora sou eu não é só vontade e
tranquilo
[Aplausos]
olha a cara de deus do céu e não tem
nada
brincamos que tenham gostado do meu
homem do google todo que já sabem só nós
conseguimos atingir a meta dos 200 mil
likes neste vídeo eu vou comprar uma
tranquila se ao mesmo pessoal que quem
vai até a próxima